The talk is graph machine learning in
practice from fraud analysis to graph
rag. And actually a bit of overlap. I'm
really interested to hear we're talking
similar subjects.
Um
as background I should say that uh
Hans has a degree in physics from
Hamburg University.
Started out in research at Oracle 25
years ago.
And uh please join me in welcoming Hans.
Okay. Paco, thank you. Thank you very
much for the nice introduction. Um as
part of my physics degree, by the way, I
had the pleasure of living here in
London for a year, spending a time um my
time at Imperial College. So it still
feels feels a little bit like home to
me, which is great. Um thanks for having
me. Um
in case you were wondering why Oracle, I
mean, Oracle, you know, the database
company known for its relational
database, is actually present at the
events like this.
Um you may or may not be aware that
Oracle is not only a relational
database, but it is actually a
multi-model database. So we call that a
converged database.
Um and as part of that, we've been
offering graph technologies for ages. I
we started out with RDF graph
technologies about 20 years ago. We've
moved into property graphs uh in uh
2016. And the good news for anyone here
is
we're offering that free of charge
without additional license cost to
anybody who's got an Oracle database. So
if
you have an Oracle database, you have
the graph capabilities included. If you
have a client or you're working for a
client who's got an Oracle database,
you know, the client is um uh uh can use
that without any additional uh license
cost. And if you don't have an Oracle
database, at the end of the talk I'll
tell you where you can get a free Oracle
database if that's what you would
prefer. Now onto the topic. Uh that was
sort of my little plug on on Oracle
technologies. The the rest is going to
be pretty much
generic
graph machine learning. How do you use
or how can we use different techniques
that combine graphs and machine
learning? And I'm seeing this on three
different levels, right? The one
approach is like the most simple
approach actually is to just extract
features or use pattern matching
queries, use graph algorithms, and feed
the results into uh your favorite
machine learning framework.
The second level
um is to represent technology, uh sorry,
topology, not technology. To represent
topology of the topology of the graph as
a vector and feed that into your
favorite machine learning framework. Or
third level, uh you essentially combine
concepts of graph directly with with
neural networks. And I'll have uh one or
two examples,
customer
examples, to, you know, briefly
illustrate how these techniques um are
being used. And then at the end, because
here at the conference everyone wants to
talk about graph rag and uh retrieval
augmented generation workflows and so
on, I thought I'd give you a little bit
of an
uh example of how we're using these
techniques also uh for for graph rag.
And I hope you find that uh interesting
as well.
So,
first option,
first option is to compute different
metrics for each vector uh vertex in the
um
uh sort of um
uh
in the graph using either a pattern
matching query um or using a graph
algorithm. So you would essentially do
um
uh look at, you know, is there a
fraudulent account up to four hops away
from my destination account for a given
transaction or something? And then you
would feed that as an individual
variable into your um machine learning
platform. That's a relatively
straightforward thing. You could also do
the same thing with algorithms. You
compute whatever centrality or you
compute um
uh a community uh you you do a community
detection and then feed the result of
that as a variable uh into your machine
learning platform. That's essentially,
you know, just simple uh feature uh
engineering. Uh
I would say these days no rocket science
about this. And we have customers like
um in financial services I've been
working with uh a company from uh based
out of Bulgaria, Paysafe, who are doing
e-payments. They're using that approach
to uh figure out uh if there are
fraudulent activities uh happening in
their transactions graph. So what they
have is a conventional system which is
rule-based that takes every incoming
transaction into their system, uh
figures out if there is anything uh
uh that matches one of the rules, and
then based on that decision either um
automatically processes that transaction
or uh
um hands it off to to manual processing
or failure failure altogether. Um
they've complemented that rule-based
system with a graph database relatively
early on. We worked with them uh since
2016, 2017. Um where they were looking
at the the the typical scenario of is
there an account uh close to the
destination account of the transaction?
Um like is there three hops away, four
hops away? Is there someone who's been
involved in fraudulent activity in the
past? If that was the case, then this
thing would be handed off to manual
processing. And
as that was already a good basis, then
they started to um look for more
patterns, more sophisticated patterns,
and then uh introduced a machine
learning platform going along with it
that essentially took results from graph
queries like um
uh
do we have two accounts associated with
these um
with these customers that are linked by
the same password? Right? So if you ever
want to um
uh perform some fraudulent activity on
e-payment systems, right? Do note you
should not have one of the same password
on different accounts if you have if
you're operating with different
accounts, cuz that is a flag that's uh
that illustrates that it's mainly
fraudulent. And then based on that
result, uh they would look for different
patterns and try train a model that
would identify these uh
uh types of transactions as potentially
fraudulent. That is one of these
examples where you simply use signals
from uh the graph in some way, shape, or
form feed that into your machine
learning system as a variable.
Right? The
next level of uh oh, and by the way, you
can actually uh also uh feed that back
if oh, hang on. Feed that back uh into
your graph if you want to do further
graph analysis uh on on top of that just
for the sake of completeness.
Um the next level of kind of
sophistication
uh is uh rather than looking for
specific patterns, like find me
customers who are up to four hops away
uh from a fraudulent account or
something. Um
rather than look look then looking for
these types of specific patterns, you
can also try to find an encoding
that essentially represents the graph
structure around a given account or
around any type of vertex as a
multi-dimensional vector, right? So
essentially, you compute an embedding.
Why would you want to do this? Well,
this allows you to do two things.
One, you can uh perform vector
similarity search, right? You can look
for things which are similar but oh,
was that me?
Which are similar but not identical.
Should I move forward maybe a little bit
or back? Don't do let me know.
Whatever's
better.
Okay, thanks. Um
so that allows you to to do either this
uh similarity vector similarity search
Got it?
All right. Um so vector similarity
search or uh you can feed the whole
vector into your um machine learning
platform to essentially train train your
model. Uh but then of course you have
the challenge of how do you represent
the structure of your graph, so the
environment of every vertex um as a
vector. And there are different
techniques uh for that. Uh essentially,
um
uh
you uh
need to find a representation that uh
takes this um environment of every
vertex and maps it to a
uh multi-dimensional vectors. I I think
in the interest of of time I can't go
into the the topics of, you know, vector
similarity search and so on, but I I
know it's been discussed like in in
Paco's talk yesterday and elsewhere
already. Uh the idea, of course, being
making the predictions more accurate by
taking into account uh indirect
relationships. Like in product
recommendation, right? If you have a
conventional machine learning platform,
and you would be looking at the
properties of a customer, like the
whatever birth date or a channel on
which the customer typically uh
purchases products and whatever, and
then just look at the customer's
purchases, the products they they
actually are connected with
uh directly,
that'll give always give you a less
accurate result than what you would have
if you traverse the graph and take into
account the indirect relationships which
you get by connecting from customer to
product to customer to product and so
forth. Um and uh there are essentially
two ways to finally fundamentally
different approaches to encoding this
type of uh similarity, depending on your
use case, you would either want to look
at individual vertices,
um where you would look at the
environment of uh each and every
individual vertex,
or you would look at patterns like you
would look at um
little subgraphs or graphlets, um as as
we typically say, um to find
graphlets of similar structure. Uh and
I'll again I'll give you uh examples of
of both. Um for vertex embeddings, uh
there are techniques coming from natural
language processing which we have used
to come come from a vertex environment
to a vector representation which is
designed such that
two vertices with similar environments
similar but not identical will in vector
space be close to each other.
That's sort of the whole idea behind
this finding similarities but things
which are not identical. The way this
works is
you essentially take your little graph
like the demo graph I've got here.
You do random walks following just
traversing the graph like you have
vertex 1 2 4 8
and then 1 2 3 4 whatever. You
essentially do all of these random
walks.
When you consider every vertex as a
as a word in a sentence
and every path as a sentence then you
can use techniques from natural language
processing like word to vec
to convert that into a vector and then
you end up with a vector which is
representing your original graph in such
a way that
if there was a pattern which is kind of
similar to what you have around vertex 4
here
elsewhere in the graph these two things
these two vertices would have similar
vectors.
I said similar not but not the same. How
are our customers using this? I thought
because there's
fair amount of
attendees here in the audience also
coming from an RDF background I thought
I'd give you an example
where we are combining RDF knowledge
graphs with property graphs
because we can put a view on top of the
RDF graph to do graph traversals and
like graph machine learning and stuff.
We've been working with a
customer
in Asia in the area of
agricultural research. What they do is
they are trying to figure out
on the basis of the pedigree of a
plant in this case of a rice plant what
the properties of the next generation
will be because they are of course
looking for new variants which have you
better characteristics whether it be
higher yield or better disease
resistance and so forth. They have
represented all of their plants with
their pedigree and their properties as
an RDF based graph.
And then they created a view on top of
it and ran deep walk to compute a vertex
embedding for every plant in order to be
able to predict the next generation
of this specific variety. And they
actually got pretty
accurate results. So that was one
example of where we applied
deep walk. Another example sort of from
a different category if you want to not
do vertex embedding but you're looking
for similar graphlets
then we can essentially use a similar
technique where again there is
technology or an algorithm from natural
language processing called doc to vec
which essentially does the same random
walk type of thing but
essentially looks at paragraphs or sort
of little documents
and converts those into a graph that
represents essentially the structure of
this little graphlet in a vector form
such that if you have similar graphlets
they'll have a similar vector and then
you can do vector
similarity search on on top of that.
Essentially we're doing a random walk
like in the other case.
Each path is then like a paragraph and
rather than looking at the vertices for
the words we're using the the edges plus
we've added a couple of optimizations to
the original
sort of the naive algorithm that takes
into account multiple properties and
also the overall structure the overall
properties of the graph
and then you can start using that
on for example little knowledge graphs
and I'll come back to that example in
the graph rack section of my talk where
we have extracted a knowledge graph from
so-called suspicious activity reports in
financial services
where
we are extracting accounts and customers
and companies and transfers and
activities between them and so forth as
a little knowledge graph that has a
structure
and then you can do two things. You can
either look for cases which have a
similar
knowledge graph structure which look
kind of similar in terms of pattern
or you can use that for automated
classification right if you have a new
case coming in figuring out is that
dubious or is it not?
These are the two things which which you
can
do with this type of with this type of
thing. That's sort of the second level
right? So we've been talking about using
individual properties of the graph or
query
graph pattern matching query results as
input to machine learning. Second
approach was to generate embeddings per
vector or per graphlet feed that into a
machine learning model. The third thing
is actually to intertwine
the neural network with the graph
structure. There is
an algorithm in the literature called
graph sage which is very well known
which we've used as the basis for what
we've implemented and you can nicely use
that.
Actually
representation learning algorithm which
you can use for classification vertex
classification edge classification link
prediction. You can figure out anomaly
scores
compute embeddings and so forth. The
nice thing is unlike for example deep
walk which only works on
homogeneous graphs and only takes into
account the graph topology no properties
nothing plus it also has some challenges
if you if you have a rapidly evolving
graph because then you always need to
recompute it. Here this thing is is a
lot more robust in in that sense. There
are different variants for supervised or
unsupervised learning and what I like
about this
in particular is that we've combined it
with
a the GNN explainer algorithm again
something which you would find in the
literature that helps you to identify
which properties on each vertex or
which vertex in a in in the environment
of a given
vertex
has had a particularly high influence on
the result of for example the the
classification.
Right so
the idea is to combine the graph sorry
the the neural network with the graph. I
think in the interest of time I'm just
going to skip over this. Feel free to
talk to us over on the
at our booth afterwards if you're
interested in more more details on this
topic.
Where are we using that?
I was actually thinking about using an
example which we've been working on in
the area of online ad fraud
but
I
essentially ended up finding that
example a little bit too complicated to
explain so I'm using something which
probably all of you can relate to which
is
kind of using this type of technique for
cyber security. So anybody who's running
an IT infrastructure
particularly these days with the current
rate of
cyber criminality going on
will be interested in looking at
using log files to identify any kind of
suspicious activity from the logs. So if
you take into account the systems calls
and file accesses and network activities
and so on
finding out which patterns indicate that
there's something malicious going on.
That was sort of the idea. We're
actually using that ourselves. We as
Oracle I don't know if you know but we
we are a fairly sizeable
hyper scalar in the meantime
and we have
tons of
environments to to operate. We're using
this technique to find out if there's
anything suspicious
going on.
Basically
training the system on
typical attack patterns and historical
data that we have and then trying to
classify activity patterns as anomalous
as they come in. That is sort of the the
idea.
As you can imagine if if you have
log data at the scale as we have with
with these huge data centers
that is not the first line of defense
can't be the first line of defense
because there's just too much log data
coming in. So we have a sort of a first
step an LSTM based machine learning
model which we use to distinguish
between anything which is kind of just
noise to start with and then
only use that technique as the the
second layer. But still there is a blog
post on on this if anybody's interested
I'll be I'll be happy to point that out
to you. I thought I had it here on on
the list but
anyway so we're coming to pretty close
to
the end of of today's talk. In case you
find this interesting or useful or would
like to get your hands on it we have
end-to-end examples for example on
GitHub and I'll share the slide deck
here afterwards. Here we're just using a
citations network and showing how this
can be used
with classification based on supervised
learning
sort of nice end-to-end step-by-step
explanation
and
that brings us to the last example which
I which I wanted to go into with a
little more detail which is
as I called my talk so from fraud
analytics graph rack I wanted to talk
about
the graph rack part in the end. So, as I
alluded to earlier, we've been working
with customers in the financial services
industry on these suspicious activity
reports
which
they need to create whenever there's any
kind of dubious activity going on. And
our idea was like what has been
discussed in other talks as well to
extract a knowledge graph from these
suspicious activity reports. The good
thing about suspicious activity reports
is
they're a bit easier to deal with than
like any kind of other probes or what
you find on on Wikipedia or something
because
you have a relatively limited set of
entities and relationships which you you
need to extract, but you would you know
typically
try to find out who are the people
involved, what are the companies that
play a role, what are the relationships
between between them and so forth.
Basically, you need to
do named entity recognition. That's what
Paco was talking about
yesterday in the master class very
nicely. Right, and you have
all of these sort of individual
sentences. Adam Smith is the owner of
the account blah which opened on blah.
Account transactions include cash
deposits from Adam to company blah.
And then you need to figure out the
relationships. So, you do relationship
extraction.
And then you need to figure out that you
have co-references, right? Adam Smith in
the beginning is the Adam in the second
sentence and
things like that. So, that's
the the task. And from that you can
generate this little graph which is a
nice very compact representation of the
content of that suspicious
of these two sentences.
And then we created a pipeline. We
actually started working on this
pre
the
craze around
LLMs. So, we essentially did as I said,
entity recognition, relationship
extraction, co-reference resolution that
sort of combines that into the graph.
And we used
a pre-trained transformer model based on
BERT
to actually perform these three tasks in
three steps of one of the same pipeline.
With a little bit of
tuning, we got actually pretty good
results, but of course, that's a lot of
effort. Right? You What you need to do
in order to train or fine-tune that
pipeline, you need to take a certain set
of these suspicious suspicious activity
reports
and annotate them.
Figure out, okay, what is an entity,
what is an account, what is a customer?
How are these
related? And so you you we we've done a
fair amount of work. We we took like 100
something
of these SARs,
annotated them, used them to train the
model,
and then the results were actually
pretty good. And I only realized how
good they were when we started to redo
the same exercise with an LLM these days
cuz I mean obviously the immediate
reaction when when this whole LLM thing
came about was, okay, that should make
our lives a lot easier. We just you know
throw that at at the LLM, be a bit
creative about the prompt,
and then
have the LLM figure out what the
entities and relationships are and so
on.
A well-trained,
fine-tuned model these days, I think, is
still significantly
more accurate than any of the current
LLMs. I'm sure that'll change.
I'm sure that'll change over time. I I
mean I if I see the amount of
investment in LLMs,
it's actually quite mind-boggling. So, I
I see them catching up. I don't know
whether this is still
pretty good.
So,
just sort of my little take on that. And
just to wrap up, we can then use this
sort of end-to-end
very nicely in a retrieval augmented
generation workflow, [clears throat]
right? So, for example, if you have a
suspicious activity report, here's a new
SAR. You prompt the system, right?
Here's a new SAR. Decide
whether this is fraudulent or not and
explain your decision. Well, then what
you would want to do is as part of your
workflow, you would want to convert your
new
suspicious activity report into a little
knowledge graph. So, you do the graph
modeling.
You create the embedding.
Compare that against your
vector database. Look at vector
similarity. Find similar cases. Extract
those documents which are kind of
similar.
And then feed those into the prompt.
Then you have the the new one, maybe
three or five old ones which have been
classified in a certain way. And then
based on that, the LLM can take a
decision
as to whether this is fraudulent and
explain why this this case is maybe more
similar to one of those
rather than something else. Right? So,
that would be the end-to-end workflow.
Why would you do this maybe in an Oracle
database environment? Sorry for my one
little marketing slide which I had to
stick in here.
Um
The nice thing about the Oracle
environment in that context in these RAG
workflows is that not only do we support
the graph functionality, property graph
or RDF graph as I said,
and also the property graphs based on
the new SQL PGQ SQL 2023 standard which
interestingly has not been talked about
here very much. Folks always talk about
GQL as the This was 1 year earlier and
is also a joint effort by the Neo4j
colleagues, SAP, Microsoft, all of us
who come together and defined an
extension to
SQL to deal with
property graph
patching property graph pattern matching
queries.
So, that's implemented. We've got vector
search in the database. We've got
machine learning engine in the database.
You can use the database as a as a as a
document store. And then one thing which
just dawned on me when I was
listening to to Texas' talk earlier,
these relational technologies, they
actually have a couple of things just
built in which are just there and have
been for for decades which you can use
very nicely in a graph environment as
well if you have your graph defined as a
view on top of your relational data.
Like you can do
time travel.
You can say, "Give me the data as of
1st of May of 2024 or something."
And the database, just because it keeps
track of these changes and has always
done that, can go back in time
without you doing anything except
extending your query to say, "Oh, and by
the way, I want this graph as of
1st of May."
Anyway, so you get the database, you get
performance, scalability. Nice thing is
also you you have [snorts] a one of the
same sort of secure environment for your
graph, your relational data, your
documents, your vector store, all all in
one. And yes, we can do that on cloud
and on premises and so on. If you find
that interesting and you think Oracle,
that's always too
huge
investment, terribly expensive,
we actually do have a ton of free stuff
in the meantime. And that includes the
latest version of our database which you
can either run on premises or in a
containerized environment.
If you go to the GitHub repository,
that's actually a GitHub page which
points to all the free resources you you
get. You can go directly to
oracle.com/database/free,
which is where you can download the
latest version free of charge. Or if if
you want it even easier, you just use
the the hosted version,
the autonomous database on the Oracle
Cloud which we're also offering as a
always free offering.
Plus, if then you have it, of course
then you want to do something with it.
And in order to be able to do something
with it, you you probably need a little
bit of guidance. And for that, we have
what is called the live labs which are
end-to-end workflows, many of which also
have graph capabilities included or
vector search included or RAG workflows
as examples step-by-step well explained.
So, you just
spin up a sandbox system
and you can work with these kinds of
things. Right? And just for the sake of
completeness, I've added a few more
a few more links. And that gives us, I
believe, 2 minutes still for questions,
Paco. Do we still have 2 minutes for
questions? I think so, right?
Thank you.
>> [applause]
>> I have one immediate question. I was
curious about the suspicious activity
reports. Were you able to get any
form of anonymized maybe open data about
this or was this working specifically
with that?
>> That was actually work with specific
clients. We we
I don't know if you know, but as Oracle,
we also have an applications
business which
has our graph technologies embedded into
a um
crime financial crime and compliance
type of dashboard thing. And those teams
are working with the major banks.
And that's where they sort of got the
data from. So, that And for And for
Unfortunately, that is not public public
data cuz that would certainly be very
interesting.
Fantastic.
Anybody else? Other questions?
There's a microphone coming.
Thank you.
>> [clears throat]
>> Thanks, Hans. Wonderful talk and really
excited about this
First time find out that now there's a
graph extension to the SQL.
It's very exciting.
My question is actually
um it's related to what the last talk
too. Was talk about time. And when you
extract entity and relationship from the
the text, you use to fine-tune model.
There's a question I
couldn't figure out how to do it. It's
It's the context of the condition. Let's
say you have a sentence of uh Mary likes
certain tea because it's late in the
evening.
And there's a ring thunder ring ring
outside. So that kind of a complex
condition when we extract from the the
sentence
often being overly simplified, but that
context might actually become important.
I wonder if you have encountered such
problem. Okay. So that that's certainly
a very hard not to crack
and
there's
I think with any kind of machine
learning technique there's always the
risk of either oversimplifying things or
ambiguity. So that
just by looking at similarities, I think
you'll get most of the cases, but you'll
always be always at risk of
misinterpreting or sort of having false
positive or false negatives. Here we we
with the accuracy which we we did sort
of based on experiments which our
colleagues from the Oracle Labs did in
Zurich,
we reached an accuracy of sort of in the
mid-80s to upper 80s percent.
Which which is actually not bad, but if
that means you're missing out on
important fraudster, that's sort of one
too many. So I I agree. These
techniques are not perfect yet and
there's particularly with anything to do
with reason
reasoning,
I think there's still
work to do.
And I I'd say that I don't have a simple
answer on that one.
Thanks.
Anybody else? Other questions?
If not, we we can take into lunch, but
thank you very much Hans. Perfect. Thank
you. Thanks a lot.
>> [applause]